hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to prove the formula for why
you could square numbers
like 334
or
667 in your head
we'll start out by proving the formula
for numbers that start with
a string of threes and end in a four
so let's take a number that has
n number of threes as its leading digits
and the number four
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to write that number
in a different form
and this number will be one third
of 10 to the n plus one
plus two thirds
so for example if you had the number 34
that would be one-third of 100
plus two-thirds
and similarly 334
is one-third
of a thousand plus two-thirds
we want to calculate the square of this
number
so on the right-hand side we're going to
square
what's in the parentheses
and we end up with three terms we have 1
9 times 10 to the power of 2n plus 2
we have 4 9
times 10 to the n plus 1
and then we have a final term of 4 9.
we're going to write these out in
decimal form
so for the number that's blue
if we take 1 9 of a power of 10
we're going to get a string of ones
in fact we're going to get 2 n plus 2
ones
and we're going to get 1 9 extra
so for example if you have
a hundred times one-ninth
that will be
11.11111
which is
plus one-ninth
so the blue term turns out to be a
string of ones two n plus two of them
plus one ninth
we can do the same thing for the green
term
when we take four nine
of the power of one
we're going to end up with that many
number of fours
plus we're going to end up with four
ninths
and finally we just copy over the four
ninths term
so we now want to add up all these
numbers together
and when we do that we get exactly the
formula that we want
this number is going to start out
with the leading digits being
1 and there will be n plus 1 of them
then when we add the digits 4
and 1 together we get 5
and we're going to end up with n of
those
and
the units digit will be 6
because we need to add up the fractions
of 1 9 4 9 and 4 9 together
so that becomes 1 and we add to the 1
and the 4.
so we prove the formula
works
we can similarly prove the formula
works for
a number that starts with a string of
sixes and ends in a seven
i'm not going to go through the steps in
detail
but it's basically the same process
that you write it out
in terms of fractions
and you collect the leading digits
and you're going to end up
proving this pattern is correct
a final question i'll ask in this video
is these are interesting formulas but is
there any mathematical importance to
them
by way of history these formulas came
about at a problem-solving session from
donald knuth at stanford in 1985.
he had posed a question of which numbers
x and x squared
are there where the digits in both x and
x squared are non-decreasing
so these particular numbers
we clearly have digits in in the numbers
and their squares which are
non-decreasing
and furthermore since the pattern holds
however many number of threes we have or
however many number of sixes
we've proved that we can produce an
infinite number
of numbers where x and x squared
are non-decreasing
i hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel
you can catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions or on twitter at
preshtalwalker